[Musica]
buongiorno per raccontarvi questa questa
storia devo devo dirvi poche cose di me
e dell'azienda per cui lavoro sono
sicuro che quasi tutti voi avete sentito
parlare del gruppo enel
non so quanti di voi sappiano che il
gruppo enel e per valore di borsa
l'azienda elettrica più importante al
mondo
sapete che siamo nella generazione nella
distribuzione nella vendita di energia
elettrica e nella generazione
io mi sono occupato negli ultimi tre
anni di generazione da fonti rinnovabili
con enel green power ed enel green power
il leader mondiale nella nello sviluppo
nella costruzione e nella gestione di
impianti che fanno elettricità da fonti
rinnovabili
quindi due grandi successi 2 grande
storie industriali italiane ma non sono
qui per raccontarvi la storia di queste
due aziende ovviamente sono qua per
raccontarvi la storia di un di un
fallimento e di che cosa questo questo
fallimento ci ha insegnato per farlo
state con me qualche minuto vi devo vi
devo spiegare come funziona il il mondo
il settore elettrico e ve lo spiego
andando via dividere il mondo in tre tre
categorie diverse
1 il primo sono circa un miliardo e
cento milioni di persone siete voi siamo
noi sono le persone che vivono nel mondo
di oggi nel negli stati uniti e in
europa che vivono nei cosiddetti mercati
maturi o mercati di sostituzione perché
sono mondi in cui la c'è forte
sovracapacità di generazione e c'è una
domanda che è sostanzialmente piatta o
in diminuzione perché abbiamo imparato a
consumare di meno a consumare meglio
cosiddetta efficienza energetica e un
mondo in transizione
un mondo in transizione verso la
decarbonizzazione verso la generazione
distribuita
è un mondo di
prosumer che non è non è un tipo di a di
prosciutto siamo noi noi possiamo ora
come ora a produrre e consumare
l'energia che noi stessi produciamo
l'energia avrà un costo sempre minore
nel futuro
e questo anche grazie grazie alle
rinnovabili e questo porterà un
cambiamento profondo perché vuol dire
che ci sarà una nuova ondata di
elettrificazione sempre più il nostro
mondo diventerà elettrico e sempre più
aziende come la mia dovranno cambiare
ti faccio l'esempio delle delle dei
veicoli elettrici veicoli elettrici sono
previsti avere lo stesso costo di un
veicolo a combustione interna
entro i prossimi quattro anni a parità
di prestazione si prevede che nei
prossimi 20 anni dei 100 milioni di
veicoli che vengono venduti ogni anno al
mondo circa il 50 per cento sarà
elettrico per me la macchina elettrica
non è un mezzo di locomozione per me che
lavoro per un azienda elettrica
la macchina elettrica e una batteria su
quattro ruote
questa batteria può fare tante cose
ovviamente consuma energia la
immagazzina ma può anche stabilizzare la
rete quindi evitare che venga costruita
nuova generazione e lo fa attraverso
delle colonnine speciali di ricarica
lo fa attraverso il software si perché
il software nel mio settore diventerà un
qualcosa di essenziale di importante nel
futuro noi sempre di più diventeremo
aziende che gestiscono sempre di meno i
propri asset e sempre di più gli assedi
terzi gli asset vostri però parlato
troppo del del mercato del mercato
nostro andrò a vedere gli altri due
velocemente il secondo è cosiddetto
mercato dei paesi emergenti cioè i
mercati che hanno bisogno di tanta
energia e qua ovviamente il mix è molto
più bilanciato costruiscono molto di più
impianti e convenzionali costruiscono
impianti rinnovabili e costruiscono
tanta generazionale distribuita e infine
c'è un terzo mercato un mercato che
nessuno di voi ha mai ha mai visto
nessuno di voi probabilmente conosce è
un mercato
senza elettricità è un mercato un
mercato buio in cui un miliardo e 200
milioni di persone si alzano la mattina
quando sorge il sole e vanno a dormire
quando il sole se ne va questo mercato è
più o meno uguale alla popolazione che
esisteva nel 1878 quando edison ha
inventato la lampadina ad incandescenza
quella che fino a ieri
usavamo in tutte le nostre case io ho
una grandissima fortuna io e altre circa
60.000 persone lavorano per un'azienda
che è cambiata tantissimo negli ultimi
anni è certo ovviamente andiamo al
lavoro per guadagnarci il nostro
stipendio i miei figli mia moglie a
tutta la mia famiglia vivono di quello
stipendio non siamo ricchi di famiglia
però abbiamo anche un'altra grande
fortuna sapendo quello che sta
succedendo in questo mondo nel nostro
settore
andiamo in ufficio pensando che possiamo
veramente cambiare il mondo e quindi ci
siamo ci siamo intestarditi abbiamo
detto un miliardo e 200 milioni di
persone senza senza elettricità non va
bene facciamo facciamo qualche cosa è la
cosa più ovvia per un'azienda che è
un'azienda tecnica è stata quella di
dire è la tecnologia e la tecnologia
cambierà il mondo noi siamo i più grandi
più bravi più forti e quindi andiamo
dove gli altri hanno fallito portiamo la
tecnologia abbiamo guardato il mondo
delle telecomunicazioni un grande
successo in particolare
dall'altra parte del mediterraneo siamo
andati dove quasi la metà di quel
miliardo e 200 milioni di persone vive
senza elettricità e io non so quanti di
voi sanno ma il 75 per cento e più della
popolazione sub sahariana ha un telefono
cellulare non hanno mai conosciuto il
telefono fisso c'è stato un salto di
tecnologia e il telefono cellulare è
diventato estremamente estremamente
importante talmente importante che il
telefono cellulare è uno strumento di
sopravvivenza senza il cellulare non si
fa business non si parla con le persone
che si conosce ma in un in un continente
così duro è così difficile
si può anche morire io non so quanti di
voi sanno che in africa in particolare
in kenya è stato inventato quasi direi
più di 15 anni fa
il mobile banking così come lo
conosciamo noi ora scambiamo denaro
tranquillamente sul telefonino ma questo
è stato inventato in kenya ha tanto
tempo fa un'azienda chiamata safaricom
si è accorta che c'era un problema
le banche sostanzialmente non sono molto
presenti e allo stesso tempo un
continente così così difficile così duro
era necessario proteggere le persone in
altrimenti venivano derubate se avevano
grosse somme di denaro e quindi ha
inventato un sistema che tramite sms e
tutta una serie di agenti sparsi sul
territorio permettesse di scambiare il
denaro paypal che probabilmente tanti di
voi utilizzano è stato inventato circa
una ventina d'anni fa in sudafrica
più o meno con lo stesso concetto quindi
abbiamo detto tecnologia
la tecnologia è quella che risolverà il
problema che darà la luce dove ci sta il
buio e e quindi abbiamo detto ok è
semplice queste persone hanno bisogno
elettricità devono studiare la sera i
bambini hanno bisogno di far girare gli
elettrodomestici con l'energia crescerà
l'economia come ha fatto la telefonia
vinceremo anche noi sarà un grandissimo
business faremo faremo una cosa
meravigliosa e e quindi abbiamo iniziato
a costruire delle piccole piccole reti
isolate con della tecnologia
meravigliosa ci siamo portati dietro il
contatore elettronico in mezzo
all'africa perché eravamo pronti a
fatturare l'energia che avremmo venduto
e guarda caso il business non andava da
nessuna parte non cresceva non succederà
nulla
non succedeva nulla sui piccoli successi
quella avevamo avevamo delle situazioni
divertenti dove il bambino studiava di
più abbia fatto anzi grassi studi da
questo punto di vista grande successo
avevamo una situazione in cui l'economia
si leggermente migliorata ma nella
realtà sta frotta di gente che veniva
non succedeva il business rimaneva lì e
allora
abbiamo deciso di riguardare la cosa di
ri studiarla e ci siamo accorti che cosa
le cose ovvie perché noi ci eravamo
innamorati della soluzione non ci
eravamo innamorati del problema e quindi
siamo andati a vedere e ovviamente la
soluzione era tecnologicamente forse
troppo avanzata non aveva un gran senso
alla fine stendere fili costanza accodi
soldi il contatore elettronico e mezzo
all'africa potete immaginare e il
secondo punto è che questa è gente che
vive di agricoltura e quindi continua
alzarsi la mattina presto a lavorare
duro tutto il giorno a tornare la sera a
casa e poi andare a dormire presto alla
terza cosa vi prego non non pensate che
siamo che siamo sciocchi la terza cosa
vi ricordate corrado guzzanti quando
quando parlava di internet spiegava come
internet era lo strumento meraviglioso
aiutava a parlare a tutte le persone in
giro per il mondo e faceva l'esempio di
lui seduto a roma che parlava con l'ab
origine australia e alla fine dello
sketch diceva ma io a questo aborigeno
che ciò da dirgli ecco era successa la
stessa cosa identica a noi ne andavamo
in questi villaggi la gente la gente ci
guardava ci ringraziava ha poi poi ci
diceva ma io questa elettricità ma che
cedevo fa era questa la situazione
avevamo fallito
ci eravamo concentrati sulla cosa
sbagliata la soluzione invece del
problema e quindi e quindi i nostri
giovani ragazzi dello sviluppo bianchi
come il latte che escono dalla bocconi
dal politecnico che vengono anche da
grandi università americane si sono
imbarcati e hanno riattraversato il
mediterraneo sono scesi sono andati in
kenya sono andati in tanzania sono
andati in etiopia e si sono ri seduti
con le persone con le persone a cui
avevamo costruito
queste meravigliose minireti si sono
seduti accanto al capo del villaggio
sotto sotto l'albero principale quello
che generalmente domina questi villaggi
e e hanno iniziato a parlare con la
gente
tutti in fila per raccontarci la loro
storia tante storie
nel racconto una su sulle tante che
abbiamo ascoltato
quindi c'è questa questa giovane ragazza
una donna con due figli abbandonata dal
marito che si è dovuta inventare
imprenditrice col telefono cellulare ha
iniziato a scambiare pesce pesce
essiccato siamo in tanzania un villaggio
all'altro e con questo ha fatto un po di
soldi e con questi soldi ha comprato due
lampade solari
le lampade solari sono delle lampadine
con una piccola batteria e un piccolo
pannellino solare che si carica durante
il giorno e fanno luce durante durante
la notte una più piccola da messa dentro
casa per uso domestico
la seconda un po più grande la messa
invece la messa fuori per illuminare la
strada
sì perché il problema vero è la
sicurezza e quindi l'energia l'energia
serve per per fare calore per dare
sicurezza
la lampada solare è più che sufficiente
in questo momento nella situazione in
cui siamo
perché serve per ricaricare il cellulare
che è fonte di vita come abbiamo detto e
sicurezza pure quello insomma l'energia
di per sé non crea sviluppo
la tecnologia non è innovazione
innovazione una parola estremamente
estremamente abusata siamo tantissimo in
economia
lo usiamo tantissimo in politica la
usiamo la usiamo tutti i giorni ormai
ovunque io non so quanti di voi sanno
che la parola innovazione viene viene
dalla botanica significa germoglio
significa ramo nuovo e quindi il
processo innovativo per avvenire ha
bisogno di un terreno fertile ha bisogno
di radici profonde ha bisogno ha bisogno
della pianta viva c'è un articolo
meraviglioso di luigino bruni che vi
consiglio di andare a leggere che parla
appunto di come l'innovazione possa
essere accostata alla botanica
e ci dice che il il contadino il
contadino potrebbe essere la tecnologia
è sì importante il lavoro del contadino
la pazienza le mani del contadino
aiutano il germoglio a fiorire ma non
possono crearlo per far sì che
l'innovazione vada avanti cresca
effettivamente c'è bisogno che la pianta
sana pianta forte e quindi bisogna
arricchire la terra bisogna proteggere
le piante deboli e bisogna bisogna
piantare tante altre piante intorno ecco
con questa idea con queste da in testa
abbiamo abbiamo reinventato un progetto
abbiamo completamente cambiato
l'approccio al al problema del miliardo
e 200 milioni di persone senza luce e e
abbiamo ri attraversato il mediterraneo
e e siamo ripartiti
siamo ripartiti convinti che dovevamo
risolverlo in maniera diversa il
problema e quindi e quindi ci siamo
rivolti a chi ci potesse potesse dare
una mano chi ci potesse aiutare a creare
l'imprenditore del settore elettrico del
futuro in africa e abbiamo iniziato a
formare una serie di persone perché in
questo caso siamo partiti da un problema
un problema vero che la migrazione la
migrazione per povertà la migrazione che
porta tutte queste persone dal
continente africano all'europa ricca
all'italia ricca che si vede così
presente anche in questa città e abbiamo
iniziato a cercare persone che
volontariamente volessero diventare
imprenditori li abbiamo che abbiamo
formati le aiutiamo a tornare a casa e
gli diamo un piccolo capitale gli diamo
il materiale che gli serve e li aiutiamo
li seguiamo per avviare la loro attività
siamo perfettamente coscienti che sono
sono sono germogli sono piantine e
pianti le deboli soltanto da alcune di
queste nascerà nascerà un albero forte
ma dei frutti che faranno ne
beneficeremo tutti
attenzione però abbiamo abbiamo
necessità tutti noi di aiutarli perché
le persone povere gli esclusi perché
possano essere veramente motore di
cambiamento del posto della loro
dell'oro della loro terra del paese in
cui vivono hanno bisogno di aiuto di
tutti noi perché perché soltanto con il
nostro supporto progetti imprenditoriali
possono essere costruiti in maniera tale
che non guardino al passato come dice
bruni per ricercare garanzie di ieri ma
guardino al futuro per ricercare
garanzie garanzia del domani di progetti
che ancora non esistono ma che
potrebbero esistere se soltanto noi
iniziamo a vedere se soltanto noi li
incoraggiamo e li e li supportiamo io ho
viaggiato tanto per lavoro sono stato
spessissimo in africa è una cosa che è
veramente bella è che quando tu a terry
la mattina distrutto e vuoi andare in
tuo albergo a riposare farti una doccia
stai per ore in mezzo al traffico un
traffico caotico anche per fare quattro
chilometri ci metti in 5 ore e e vedi un
sacco di gente che esce fuori da queste
spesso baraccopoli vestiti con l'unico
abito buono che hanno e vanno a lavorare
perché il lavoro è lavoro ovviamente ci
nobilita ci dà la possibilità di fare
tante cose che altrimenti non potremmo
fare e vedi tutti questi ragazzi che
escono da lì e sei cosciente che escono
da lì pensando che un giorno in quelle
baracche non ci torneranno
ecco da un fallimento totale
siamo arrivati a una situazione in cui
invece abbiamo capito e da quello è nato
un progetto un progetto che noi
riteniamo meraviglioso così come nei
mercati maturi le grandi dorsali
elettriche sono nate dall aggregazione
di piccoli impianti isolati
noi pensiamo che da questi piccoli
imprenditori di oggi possa nascere lo
sviluppo sostenibile del futuro di quel
continente
anche questo enel grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]